Paris say three nice things about
Lindsay Lohan Paris Hilton has nothing
nice to say about Lindsay Lohan she's
beyond Paris was a guest on Tuesday
nights watch what happens live with Andy
Cohen where she played an epic game of
lead the fin in which she did not plead
the fifth say three nice things about
Lindsay Lohan she's beyond that's that's
a pretty nice way to say that she's
beyond lamb an embarrassing this isn't
the first time Paris has put the verbal
smackdown on lilo the former friends
have had a tumultuous past in 2006 that
Lindsay was reportedly seen kissing
Paris's boyfriend at Stavros Niarchos
just days before they broke up Paris
you've recently said that you never want
Lindsay Lohan's name spoken in the same
sentence as yours and how could we ever
forget when tourists and her friend
Brandon Davis called Lindsay Lohan a
fire earlier in the show at Paris shut
down rumors about joining the cast of
The Real Housewives first of all I'm not
a housewife I'm not married I probably
never will be and of course she revealed
what her tagline would be that's hot
[Music]